how did you come about lifting skipper
was great quite oven Punisher yeah yeah
timmy was actually the the Tim's covers
for the comic that Marvel sent me after
I'd turned down the role a couple of
times I said it's just you know the
superhero thing I just not I mean it's
fun for four people some people but I'm
just I wasn't a fan but then they sent
me the Brad she recovers to the show to
the book and and they had such a gritty
realistic feel to them and I said well
if we could do something like that that
would be terrific and then I out for
Mayan I asked them if they would want to
do a poster a special poster just for
comic-con by Tim as meat for as me as
The Punisher which which they agreed to
and so we set up a little photo shoot in
Santa Monica I guess they brought you up
from San Diego right still living down
there yeah and we got together a little
photo shoot house in Santa Monica and
that's when Tim and I first met then we
just hit it off instantly and became
really good friends yeah it's funny too
because when I first found out there was
going to be a Punisher movie I wanted to
be a part of it and I knew that galiyon
heard was producing it and I'm a
longtime fan of Gail's work and I was
like how do I get involved with this so
I got a hold of the only person that I
thought might get me in touch with Gale
Anne Hurd which was a frank darabont and
Darabont said I'll do you one better
i'll introduce you to her husband her
and jonathan ends layer who's directing
the movie by the way our dear friends of
mine so he called Jonathan Hensley and
John called me and and we talked about
doing all kinds of stuff me doing all
kinds of stuff on the film conceptually
and like just being a big part that when
it came time and I gave him the idea for
the whole teaser trailer and when it
came time to do the movie Jonathan said
I can't hire you and I said
why and he said well Marvel says they
own all these covers what do we need you
for and I said oh well how disappointing
and so I called the aria rod one of the
producers and I said you know designing
the punisher is the last thing I was
going to do on that movie that's done it
was a lot of other things I said but I
said you know what you should think
about is at the very least is I would
love to do a poster a teaser poster for
the film like I do the covers but with
Thomas Jane instead of my Punisher model
and so that was going on while tom was
advocating for me which is just strange
and ari said something like well yeah
we'll keep that in mind thanks to him
and and I didn't know re at the time
necessarily and so I think a month or
two went by and then he emailed me out
of the blue and he goes I got terrific
idea we'd love for you to do posters for
the and yeah so that so meanwhile they
did they were also doing posters for the
movie and they were just terrible and
when we went through them everybody just
rejected these photo put realistic
posters of me and John Travolta
Photoshop heads you know but then Tim
had done some work too and Tim's work 10
Tim's poster work ended up being the
poster for the film itself yeah they
they took well yeah we ended up doing 5
teaser posters and doing some big
release at comic-con and then they hired
me to do the theatricals so then when i
was doing press in san diego got
together with Tim and I pitched him this
idea I had for a comic and that turned
out to be bad planet Tim hooked me up
with steve niles who taught me how to
write for comics and we formed a company
together me and Tim and Steve called raw
studios and we're still at it today you
know we just put out a book called dark
country which we brought some copies
here and that was a graphic novel
adaptation of the movie that that we did
and Thomas OTT always been a big fan of
I got in touch with him and I actually
was in Paris and we went out to dinner
and I pitched him this idea and Thomas
agreed to do the graphic novel and then
we were also working on a werewolf book
with another native son Sean O'Connor is
a ferment from London and and we've just
kind of kept at it dude doing our
boutique comic book stuff and having a
lot of fun you know very low output put
high quality yeah it's more of a
boutique kind of like you know we're not
in it to put out like a line of comic
books we're in it to develop and nurture
our own kind of projects and we're you
know it's interesting that tom was not
interested in doing a superhero when
they offered him the punisher because
he's a lifelong comic collector more
while his I think your your proclivity
was more for the Underground's and and
you know the oldc comic books and and
things of that nature so I guess on that
level i can see why superheroes weren't
something that was jumping out at you
yeah I just I just personally never
really really got into it couldn't see
yourself walking around in a spandex
costume yeah just too bad it'll be a lot
richer did when you're right I'll you
put spot a solid how tendrils or-- you
influence when you draw how the
rightness wrenched well does this work
to Kevin G but he says I'm and roll we
have a simpatico you know Tom Tom and I
do and I don't know whether it's where
near the same age and from the same part
of the country and we grew up with the
same stuff but he he turns me on to
stuff that I'm I was never into but um I
don't know if that goes both ways but uh
you know tom is I always say that Tom's
kind of my muse in a way like with
covers because he's such a chameleon as
an actor you know he's done post for
Nick Fury for me he's been el Borak
Robert E Howard's el Borak he's Cal
McDonald and you know and and I'll
because I shoot a lot of photos of them
here and there and or on movie projects
I end up
using that stuff you know in my own work
and so um I East kind of my De Niro if I
was Scorsese you know but I think my he
trusts my sensibilities to you know as
you know with raw studios I'm I do all
the ad design all the you know all the
art direction and stuff like that and he
does as well you tease out the books and
we do the art direction inside all the
books well he does a lot of it to i mean
he's very hands-on with the artists he's
an artist too you know and I in he's a
creator and part of that creation is
working on all those levels in the
development of something and I'm an
artist who can't draw he designed our
bed planet logo de Guise tell us a bit
more balance and dog country people
haven't seen it yet and what is it about
the coming of it world it's up eating I
don't know I mean I think graphic novels
are just so imaginative and I love the
fact that they're a indigenously
American art form I that they're in
other so relatively new the the the
paper canvas is you know it's just as
imaginative as as you want to get I mean
any kind of story you can tell you can
do through comics you could the bad
planet story that we did if you did that
as a movie it would be a 400 million
dollar film you know and and there's
their novels with pitchers they can be
poetry they can be sublime that can they
can tell in small intimate stories you
know or they can be you know they can
encompass multiple universes there it's
a really amazing canvas and you see with
shows like this you see the the breadth
and the depth of just how
you know varied all that imaginative
world is and there's an audience for
whatever you can create in that world
it's very specific you know it's uh
there's so many different styles of art
you know from Frank Miller to wally wood
to horrendo to means just to Bradstreet
there's just so much there's so much
that you can do with that world visually
that it's always too it's always it's
always just held a fascination for me in
terms of story and and the marriage of
art and story is something that is also
so you know it's a it creates its own
mystique in a way the artist that you
choose to tell the story is sort of that
paints the palette of the kind of world
that you're going to enter you can tell
so much with without words you know and
then and then of course you can have
fantastic writing you know that's
there's comic books out there there as
well written as any novel with all the
simple sublime and poetry and so it's
it's really captivating you know it's
always captivated my imagination and and
I i try to stay open to all different
styles you know kind of get into all
different kinds of like Tim said I'm a
big fan of the underground comics that
started in the 60s and and but then I
also like really cartoony stuff and then
more of the Tim and I lean toward a sort
of the more realistic illustrate
Illustrated illustrative style of book
but but then you know we work with
somebody like Tom Assad who does
scratchboard he takes a black sheet
paper any scratches white into the paper
and that's
amazing and unique the thing too with
comics is as a creator there isn't you
know with a film project you have to you
have to raise money there's a budget
there are all these limitations there's
all these spokes in the wheel all these
you know facets you have to work with to
be able to make that thing happen and
along the way your vision oftentimes is
watered down and homogenized and focus
grouped and you know suited as i like to
call it and in comics your only
limitation is your time and your
imagination and it's like Tom said you
can use a small intimate story that if
you were you know like and very often if
I do sequential I stage it as a play and
I photograph it and then i work from
those photos to create the stylized
artwork and that can be a bit of a
production but but Tomic's can be the
small intimate thing up to something
that could be a 400 million dollar film
you know a Pacific Rim you know and
that's the magic of it you know you
don't need anyone but yourself really
and then figure out a way to publish it
and today I mean you just kick start
that thing right as long as you can get
enough people interested in it you can
get it out there or you could go to
someone like image who is if they think
your book is worth it will publish that
book for you and I think that's pretty
amazing well you're also working with a
lot of different artists even if you're
making a book and then that way it's a
great great practice for for for movies
because you're still working with a
colorist and a letterer and and the
illest in the penciler and the incre and
the printer and then all those things
have corollaries to to film and if
you're organizing all that you're
working with all these different people
to bring a specific vision on it to life
and I think it's great practice for for
making movies yeah there's no great
stretch there you know it's that's doing
the same thing in a different venue so
for me it's great training
as a director Tim and I are working on a
couple of movies too I wrote a Western
last year we're going to hopefully shoot
it in the spring but that the that
experience in getting into films is just
a direct result of working on these
comics and sort of learning the ropes
that way you know it's sort of like the
Purdue sauriol side of creativity which
would you have to have it gives you
confidence too because you know it
starts out of something that you're not
you know maybe so sure about but once
you've been through the ropes with
putting together a book like that you
kind of see that hmm I think I can work
with these other facets and make that
happen and raw too is a company that's
not just a comet company it's you know
we're developing like Tom said film Tom
produced an album last year for rusty
mm-hmm now we've made an EP for rusty
blades and so it's like whatever kind of
like creative format we're into we try
to make it happen and put it out there
and that's that's exciting you know
there's no limitation you know it's not
just one type of thing you mentioned you
working on various movies at the moment
what kinda give us a little bit of a
tease about what kind of thing they all
kind of genre what kind of subjects he
might be involved the sort of thing well
we got the Western that's the farthest
along it's the first long we've got a
great cast and Nick Nolte got Nick and
we've got some other terrific actors to
come on board for that and we're working
on the other other project is sort of a
hard-boiled kind of in the vein of the
old Donald Westlake novels sort of one
of those hard-boiled style stories Phil
rano who directed dirty laundry and I
working on a project miniseries so we're
putting that together
were our book the lichen which is sort
of like the Magnificent Seven and set in
the 1700s hunting hunting werewolves
period werewolf period where we'll story
that might carry is also from England
wrote for us that's going to be that's
our first project that we that we
deliberately started out to make a comic
book and then turn that into a film so
we really proud of that we have Sean
O'Connor doing the art also from England
we're working with a lot of Brits about
a child over here a lot of talent tell
us about the west and with Nick Nolte
what kind of period we talk anymore such
a bit oh the Western it takes place in
the 1870s and it's a bit of a hero's
journey it's a bit of a treasure of the
sierra madre it's it's very much classic
western gothic more in the knee yeah
there's definitely a sort of a almost a
gothic element Oh Miriam yeah so it's a
hero's journey kind of a hoe marryin
kind of a teacher so there's a lot of
little elements of it that make it a
it's it's a mythical kind of experience
a road picture kind of it if you will or
a saddle picture it was those Raiders
Indians and buried treasure it's called
a magnificent death from a shattered
hand and there was actually a submission
the young writers submitted that script
by with that title to us and we try to
read that we have a lot of we get a lot
of submissions every week and we try to
read as much as we can but that title
sort of stood out and the story was
really really cool so we option the
screenplay from a guy named Jose
apprentice who wrote the original draft
and I worked on it for about a year
lifted in the shape and it to turn out
great you know it's very much a throw
back Western in the vein of howard hawks
and John Ford and everybody sort of
wants to do this spaghetti-western type
thing and there's the elements of that
in this Western for sure but I think for
a Western to be successful you have to
go back to the roots of what makes what
maids Western so interesting in the
first place and I think a lot of the
modern westerns try to modernize the
Western tail and and I they have not
been successful but if you stick to the
basics like Unforgiven I guess that's
really the most recent Western
generating cuff that did what that
really did well the two films that I
think you could compare this Western to
would be there will be blood and no
country for old men